A lot of people have talked about
China's growing role in Africa.
I personally am not a particularly
either upset or surprised by this
because realistically what's going on is
simply the increased role that China is
playing in the globe at large,
uh,
as you would expect a growing economic
power,
uh,
to play,
and it's focused on resource plays.
It's focused on buying up and securing
energy sources and materials and various
things that will fuel the continued
growth of the Chinese economy.
Uh,
and it's exactly what you'd expect.
It certainly has some adverse
consequences because since the Chinese
don't care about various kinds of human
rights issues and they don't care about
political freedoms,
they're more than happy to deal with
dictators.
They're more than happy to overlook all
sorts of trouble if it,
if there are particular immediate needs
are taken care of,
but you know what,
in the long run,
the Chinese might well find that
stability and sustainably healthy,
viable local communities and,
and policies are in their best interest
as well.